hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute das spiel movistar planet das wird
mega spannend was ist das hier unten für
ein was erstelle deinen movies da
zufälliges mädchen oder zufälliger junge
wollen wir ein mädchen oder ein junge
sein wir hatten das schon öfters mal so
oft du heilige ich wollte mich hier
drüber lehnen da da über dem bauch über
die ablehne und das war gerade echt ein
richtiger urschrei einfach von mir also
was ich sagen wollte wir hatten ja schon
öfters mal die auswahlmöglichkeiten
zwischen verschiedenen sachen das halt
nehmen wieder unseres altbewährte 1 eur
stückzahl seite ist junge und der adler
seite des mädchen okay wir sind wie
zeige ich dass jetzt da wir sind ein
junger meine damen und herren das
bedeutet wir wählen jetzt hier den
jungen aus und können uns dir auch er
sieht genau so aus wie ich hat der typen
gebrochenen fuß also ich habe definitiv
was habe ich denn finden nase ich würde
sagen die nase dann das ist mein mund
ich habe grüne augen also ich hab das
gesicht jetzt mal ein bisschen verändert
und ich muss sagen er sieht eigentlich
mit la paz wer denn dafür muss die ganze
zeit machen die haare passen jetzt auch
eigentlich mit meinen oder einen kann
ich nicht auch ein theoretisch bei der
lippe noch ja genau da kann ich auch
noch eben die farbe ändern damit das
auch alles passt shirt würde ich sagen
nehmen wir am besten hier das hier genau
da können wir die farbe dann auch noch
eben anpassen dass es zu meinem augen zu
meinen augenbrauen meinen haaren et
cetera passgenau haben wir auch die hose
ziehe ich natürlich also eine kurze
knackige hohe sicher damit auch alles
übereinstimmend nehmen wir das natürlich
so mit mir wacker spitzenschuhen gegen
den staat
[Musik]
das in ich meine damen und herren ok
getan wir haben es als ob ich mich da
als anmelden muss horn kraft wer war das
den kontakt nicht verfügbar ist nehmen
wir uns dann einfach laserdrucker das
wollte mich eigentlich verarschen die
ich bin ein cutie 96 ja es war sodann
lebt jetzt mal dieser mobistar planet
und wir sind jetzt auch schon da wo wir
hingehören auf
du siehst umwerfen da raus ich mach
einfach mal ein ratschlag habe ein paar
tolle geschenke für dich okay ich nehme
das hier erstmals 200 points tisch mit
frühstück ein hund wurde dem morgen das
geschenk okay dann hole ich mir das
geschenk worden findet freunde von
deiner schule
ich gehe nicht zur schule ich bin kind
die 96 hab spaß ich dachte ich bin jude
96 hier kann ich jetzt eingeben was ich
gerade mache irgendwie dann kann ich
hier noch auswählen welches leider
haustier ich mitnehmen will
aber ich schreibe erstmal was mache ich
gerade ich bin zu beliebt um mit euch zu
reden
oder nehmen wir mal hier was ich finde
haus ich hab doch und bekommen ersten
geschenke ich nochmal das geschenk auf
was habe ich jetzt bekommen plus 10 15
war okay kratz jetzt auch wieder
eingesetzt ich habe ein neues level
erreicht das ging relativ schnell jetzt
denn das nicht für ein spiel alter
überall sind einfach geschenke wo ich
mir die ganzen sachen holen kann die
ausspiele
wir haben spiele schick machen was kann
ich mich hier nein das ist doch jetzt
nicht party-girl 02251 beurteilt wer
hübscher als ich bin
kleiden wie ein vampir ich bin definitiv
der beste vampir achter zeit will ich
mir mit spielen das spiel ist blöd so
wir gehen einfach mal zurück wir gehen
jetzt in movie trauen wir schauen ob ich
dann eine große karriere zum
schauspieler endlich umsetzen kann das
heißt wir gehen hier erstmal in lux und
können uns dann dort jetzt aus cool wie
kann ich mehr haustiere holen das heißt
ich habe 245 konz davon kann ich mir
eigentlich tatsächlich gerade nicht
kaufen 150 kosten die fische okay dann
hole ich komme ich um mich um mehr
fische in pink ich habe schlechte kochen
glückwunsch ich habe schon wieder ein
neues level erreicht ich hole mir die
latschen hier und die kann ich kann ich
mir die dann auch direkt schon anziehen
irgendwo ist es möglich mein wagen kommt
ist er ja bla bla
das muss doch irgendwo sein dass ich
wenn ich zurück shopping spiele sowie
town
wenn man dann handeln gesichtsausdruck
und freund blabla wie kann ich denn
meine sachen da so kleidung wechseln
jetzt ich mir dies klappen wenn ich im
winter gehen die spätere vom freunde wir
gehen shoppen und zwar in die
schönheitsklinik denn dort habe ich für
geld was ich bin einfach richtig pleite
das ist nicht wahr ich kann mir als die
sonne nase mit zu schnäuzen wählen und
ich kann mir auch als wir singen machen
ich kann das was gibt denn als vip hat
man einfach so kranke möglichkeit und
ich bin einfach nur sondern musiker
sieht spitze aus von ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht was ich noch in diesem
spieler das machen soll deswegen würde
ich sagen wenn jeder irgendwelche ideen
zu haben beziehungsweise wollte dass ich
das weiter spiele oder so keine ahnung
das ganze hier ist kein placement oder
so mir wurde einfach gesagt spiel
movistar planet und ich hab mir gedacht
ja so schlimm kann es nicht sein
ich habe mich getäuscht wenn ihr mehr
vollzeit man mit einer bewertung
schreibt mir vielleicht tipps in die
kommentare wie kann ich geld verdienen
kann ich mir irgendwie arbeiten
ich weiß nicht